in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us today is a Halloween of
course and for kids that means costumes
and candy but door-to-door
trick-or-treating can be challenging for
kids with physical disabilities we
visited one Utah Hospital that found a
creative solution to make sure all kids
get a treat this Halloween I really wish
I could have superpowers there's trouble
then I could save the world it's a big
dream for a little kid who's already
overcome big challenges kool Spencer was
diagnosed with spina bifida a birth
defect of the spine when his mom was
five months pregnant okay if essence
were the way now five years old he has
no problem keeping up with his older
siblings
except when it comes to
trick-or-treating it was hard for him to
reach the door to collect candy get much
closer Halloween's a hard thing when you
are in a wheelchair or if you are in any
state of disability four-year-old Cooper
basket who was born with a form of
dwarfism faced similar challenges
trick-or-treating was distraught because
he wouldn't get candy his brother would
bring it back for him
and he slowly quickly lost interest when
basket and Spencer heard about the
wheelchair costume clinic at Shriners
Hospital for Children they signed up
immediately the kids submit their ideas
and hospital staff and volunteers design
the costumes but it's when the kids
arrive that the volunteers work their
magic
with the help of cardboard PVC pipe some
paint and glue kids in their wheelchairs
are transformed into everything from a
DJ spinning records and Disney's Moana
and her canoe to Superman in his phone
booth and Rapunzel in her Tower Scott
Jerome works for Shriners he says the
program helped 32 kids this year the
largest group since it started four
years ago it's fun to see them be a
child and enjoy what they're doing the
costumes cost up to a hundred and fifty
dollars to build but the program is
supported by donations and dozens of
creative volunteers Jerome says the
flashy creations encourage candy givers
to leave their doorsteps just the trick
to help these kids get their treats I
think what brings us back as well as the
stories that we get from the families
that Halloween starts to come to them
Cole is ready to save the world I think
all parents with kids with disabilities
just really want their kids to have the
experience of what a normal child would
have and when you get a glimpse of it it
just warms your heart and Cooper is for
ki a popular toy story for character in
his RV just to see his little face light
up and spark up and how excited he was
when they roll away in their costumes
you've made a dream come true for them
it's a timely reminder that costumes not
only allow kids to become someone else
they can help show the world who they
really are it's just bad
[Music]
for CBS this morning Jamie yuccas Salt
Lake City that's a great Batmobile
I'll say I like what he said sometimes a
child just our children just want to be
kids yes and fit in just like everybody
else it's so well done some great work
by the Shriners there nicely nicely done